they fought and died for years alongside
United States forces in the effort to
defeat ISIL but US President Donald
Trump is defending his decision to
withdraw US troops from northeastern
Syria allowing turkey to attack the
Kurdish fighters we help the Kurds and
we never gave the Kurds a commitment
that we'd stay from there cuz 400 years
of protective they've been fighting with
the Turks for 300 years that people know
of and nobody ever committed G of you do
this we're going to do that we're going
to stay with you forever nobody ever
said that Trump has faced bipartisan
criticism in the US Congress about the
troop pullout and his decision to drop
turkey sanctions as part of the
ceasefire agreement that expires on
Tuesday
and despite anger at home and abroad
Trump maintains the ceasefire is holding
even as Turkey's president Rech of tyub
air Dewan is vowing to continue his
military campaign the White House has
promised to lift sanctions placed on
Turkey as part of its ceasefire deal but
Trump isn't ruling out more in the
future we have a power that nobody
thought we had to the extend it's called
sanctions it's called tariffs no tariffs
the hell they're product coming here
they send tremendous amounts of steel to
the United States and other things Trump
also maintains his goal is to keep a
2016 campaign promise to bring troops
back to the United States his defense
secretary who is in the region traveling
to Saudi Arabia late Monday says some
troops may remain in Syria to secure oil
fields while others continue fighting
against ISIL in Iraq the purpose of
those forces a purpose of those forces
working with the SDF is to deny access
to those oil fields by Isis and others
who may benefit from their revenues that
could be earned given the tenuous nature
of the ceasefire agreement with Turkey
Democratic leaders in the US Congress
are promising to introduce their own
bipartisan sanctions against Turkey to
reverse what they say is a humanitarian
disaster unleashed in
Syria by President Trump Kimberly
hellcat al Jazeera the White House